computer können gehackt werden daran
haben wir dürfen gewöhnt und das
bewusstsein für diese gefahr gehört
inzwischen zum alltag und wir sind
vorsichtig aber dass ein gehirn gehackt
werden könnte und wir uns davor schützen
müssen
das könnte bald schon realität werden
die wann und wo das alles jetzt im blick
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
gedankenlesen bisher war das focus focus
von irgendwelchen zauberkünstlern im
fernseh unterhaltungsprogramm doch das
könnte bald anders werden facebook chef
mark zuckerberg hat eine vision zitat
ich denke in ein paar jahrzehnten werden
wir gedanken aufnehmen und sie wie heute
ein foto teilen
da gibt es schon die forschung die zeigt
das wird möglich sein
zitat ende die entwicklung von brain
computer interfaces also gehirn computer
schnittstellen schreitet immer weiter
voran die möglichkeiten mit dem gehirn
geräte zu steuern mit zum beispiel
künstlichen armen poeten durch das
gehirn gesteuert dinge zu greifen oder
in virtuellen welten spielfiguren zu
bewegen werden immer weiter verbessert
werden ja schon darüber berichtet wie
ein flugzeug mit gedanken gesteuert
werden kann
das ganze beruht auf brain computer
interfaces das heißt dass elektroden am
kopf die schwachen signale des gehirns
netten und verstärken computerprogramme
können diese signale dann nutzen um
wiederum angeschlossenen geräte zu
steuern noch sind die möglichkeiten
relativ eingeschränkt das interface muss
wer bewusst gesteuert werden sonst
funktioniert es nicht so muss zum
beispiel für ein jahr in gedanken die
faust geballt werden und für ein nein
zum beispiel mit dem fuß gewippt werden
da beide befehle in verschiedenen
regionen des gehirns gegeben werden kann
ein computer beide gehirnaktivitäten
erkennen und vor allem unterscheiden
doch die interfaces und vor allem die
software werden immer weiter entwickelt
mit entsprechender kann also günstiger
intelligenz ausgestattet konnten
computer so auch immer besser
analysieren was die nutzer denken
kombiniert mit dem surfverhalten könnten
immer detailliertere erkenntnisse über
den nutzer gesammelt werden am ende
könnte es wirklich zum gedankenlesen
führen wir kennen das vielleicht auf
eigene erfahrung so besser ihr einen
menschen kennt desto genauer wisst ihr
was er denkt fühlt und vielleicht auch
wünscht ihr könnt ihn
wünsche sprichwörtlich von den augen
ablesen ein computer könnte das in
zukunft vielleicht noch besser versorgt
mit informationen über nahezu das
komplette leben über smartphone computer
intelligenten geräten in der wohnung wie
kameras und sensoren darüber der mimik
und dem hirnströmen könnte das gehirn
tatsächlich gehackt werden
eine gespenstische vorstellung die
hirnforscherin tamara bonazzi von der
washington university hat in einem
experiment die möglichkeiten ausgelotet
wie hat die hirnströme gemessen
denn probanden in einem computerspiel
für sekundenbruchteile bilder von
personen logo von kaffeehaus ketten oder
fotos von orten gezeigt wurden
da die abbildung nur extrem kurz gezeigt
wurden konnten die probanden die
eigentlich nicht registrieren
den testpersonen waren wir also
verborgen nicht den brain computer
interfaces konnte die veränderungen die
hirnströme messen
jetzt könnte eine person in abhängigkeit
von der heftigkeit der reaktion relativ
einfach manipuliert werden
der serie blackmore werden menschen so
immer erschreckendere bilder gezeigt
weil die verbundene software lernt vor
was der betroffene die größte angst hat
ein einfaches jeden menschen schnell und
einfach in panik zu versetzen
ein horrorfilm wäre nichts dagegen zitat
wir müssen jetzt darüber nachdenken
während der forschung direkt mit
rechtswissenschaftlern soziologen und
ethik am zusammenzuarbeiten
nur dann haben wir die chance sichere
und ethische geräte zu entwickeln das
sagt tamara bonatz und was sagt ihr
diskutiert es in den kommentaren
da kein video mehr bei pixum verpassen
drückt mehr mit einem klick hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht
mehr einen auf die glocke zu geben
ihr werdet schon sehen gesagt bleib dran